maybe my biggest worry which is like
what if I really really really love this
and I have to like I have to come back
like every week to get my esteemed or my
life won't be right hi I'm Nikki from
cocoon holistic spa and we're gonna have
gentlemen do a treatment called the ACE
team which is literally a steamer for
your anal area like the higher it goes
like the rating gets like oh yeah more
inappropriate it's like or a pg-13 oh
we've known each other for seven years
and I think it's time for us to get her
butt holes seam together and really
become butt hole brothers these wash
they wash these have they watch this
we've known each other for a multiple
years we're pretty close we're good
friends were bad went to college
together she was saying earlier that
it's it's like drinking tea except like
through your ass I feel like it's gonna
bring us together they'll be sitting on
this beautiful chair and the steam of
the Chinese herbs will be actually going
up there perineal area steam will help
give them a good detox yeah yeah we're
we're excited and scared
Oh oh my god I'm actually terrified I'm
terrified are sleep numbers oh this is
hard to have get out
the only Lakers weren't is like like
literally it's like my butthole it's
really great for hemorrhoids it's good
for any kind of stomach issues mm-hmm
she said if you go to attend it's like
gonna boil apparently if you turn it all
the way up it quote boils your balls
it's like honestly the weirdest
sensation but it's not unpleasant do
butthole sweat the buttholes do sweat a
lot great for her acting and balancing
your hormones it's not that I'm
disappointed but when I signed up for
this I expected like go with a friend go
up to ten that's my two major pieces of
advice for an ace team I think you have
to do this with someone that you're
comfortable with buttholes demon might
be my new thing if we had these Thrones
we would be on them for a half hour
every day I've never been more proud of
my butthole
I'm not gonna lie I think this did
nothing but bring us even closer and
this might be a new thing we do on the
weekends to our buttholes to the next
level yes let me trade ya hole that's
good I'll just turn that down I'll turn
that down
Oh